[Music]
alright here we are happy to be back
another week we got some gigs coming up
I just added a show in Phoenix
stand up live fart Knicks Arizona I'm
part of it I added a show Thursday
December 7th here's what's going on that
week so far December 8th The Early Show
is sold out The Late Show has about a
hundred tickets left and Saturday both
shows are sold out so we added one
Thursday December 7th in Phoenix after
that it's off to Hawaii going to do the
Performing Arts Center in Maui
December 14th and the Hawaii theatre in
Honolulu on Saturday December 16th get
tickets at Tom Segura calm / tour and
yeah scoop them up before they're gone
gene what about you I'm talking about
2018 now January 12 I'm at the Pasadena
Ice House February 2nd 3rd in short Lake
titties Utah at wiseguys comedy club
February 23rd the Colusa Casino and then
March 30th and 31st in Portland Oregon's
at hiriam comedy krub
so come check me out there tickets at
christina p online nice and our great
guest today you may know him from going
to church regularly and he's gracing us
with first time in years that he's been
back on our show it is the great Jose
Joey
Coco Diaz good morning and just to get
it out of the way let people know you're
gonna be in Sacramento Sacramento the
7th 8th and 9th oh great I'm in the same
boat as you
have they sold down Friday first show
sold out so we got two shows left that's
it
we were walking the third fourth and
fifth oh he's doing shows with wheeler
oh that's fine he's a great guy he's
great no vote either Observatory in San
Diego and Observatory in Santa Ana let's
see how calmly country yeah well there
you go you know what it is Lincoln
didn't do you still get you still get
invitations 20,000 quest a week yeah
Lincoln say much on Facebook page they
had to work with swell do you have a
profile on Lincoln din I think somebody
actually just broke down and made one
for me let's get this show started we're
gonna open the show and we'll get into a
whole bunch of stuff with Joey Diaz why
did you abandon this tent and what are
you do you want it to have a home you
want me to find you at home guys you're
not taking care of it look at me like
welcome to your mom's house so we got
the the cat lady here because Joey is a
cat man you know that he loves cat I do
know that how many do you have
seven seven he's like he's a cat
whisperer
like he really connects with cats yeah I
love my babies yeah and this lady right
here loves cats - she's mad at this
neighbor because she's saying that the
neighbor is not taking care of the cat
[Music]
she obviously comes by your house and
pisses you off that was your the one
that said people should be responsible
[Music]
she's really upset
yeah she's saying that he's not taking
care of this cat this is how my mother
used to yell people really like over a
really mundane shit she'd be like you
fucking motherfucker yeah fucking bitch
the fucking she hated cat she was just
kind of other people like all the time
and she hated cats there was one cat we
lived in an apartment complex used to
piss on our art doormat and she waited
for the cat to come and she kicked it
she would fucking open our door and she
kicked it down the stairs it never came
back I guess no but then she'd find the
owner and be like you motherfucker
you're fucking got pcs or little one my
fucking door you fucking yeah well
what'd you do Joey does your cat wander
in other people's yards no by the house
other strictly house yeah I can't sleep
at night knowing my little fucks are
outside yeah getting attacked by a
raccoon or something like that now was
it was it a like a thing for your wife
to get used to like where was she
already in the cat's - in other words no
we weren't we were together she had a
kidney that was it that was that first
started dating she had a kid and did you
have a cat already I'm dick oh okay like
cats I don't even really yeah I didn't
have any idea and then way
where we lived in Hollywood there was a
lot of cats and they were dying in the
backyard so I would wake up in the
morning be three dead kittens oh my god
Rock so we started saving them and
calling different organizations and they
pick them up and feed them oh I didn't
know how you got in yeah then one by one
I started bringing them upstairs and
they became you know somebody would go
I'm moving in a month I want because
they were Siamese it was gorgeous and
they go I'm a moving save me one then
they call me back and go well my
roommate has an elephant so no I can't
have a fucking cat yeah yeah yeah so I
let stuck with the cold love them that
one she is then I found homes for four
of them I had five how would you find
homes
different people different girls guys
acting classes whatever and then I moved
to the valley with six and I moved to
the valley there was one that started
hanging around the house just hanging
out with me at night I would get home
from the store and whistle and it would
fucking come to me if I would walk down
the corner it would follow me yeah and
the owner came through and then she was
I can't control her but I obviously you
can she pays attention to it and she got
attacked by a possum hmm and she
couldn't stay outside no more so lady
just said just take her Wow she's mean
that's guys it's so funny to me like and
I don't know why it's like this maybe
it's like this to other people cats to
me or just it's not that I have any
issue of them they're like a foreign
language to me I mean like I I don't
know how to gauge cats I don't know what
to expect from cause I never grew up
with them I've never spent time with
cats so like to me like a dog
feels familiar yeah I I kind of I kind
of know what to expect from a dog I know
how to approach a dog I know you know I
know dog behavior pretty much like
having grown up with dogs with cats I'm
always like I don't know what what I was
supposed to do well cuz it's all their
rules I feel like they gotta tell you
what's up they tell you what's up right
you tell a dog what's up in cat world
they have to choose you like what Joey
was saying like that cat chose Joey
yeah and respects him and then but do
they pick a person what's interesting is
that it came to him later in life like I
would have
he was like growing up with cats no but
you just figured cats out by the way
later my friend growing up out of cat
yeah that was a fucking get that oh he
was a warrior yeah he was missing him
here aha his name was frisky and I still
remember one particular morning when you
know you get fucked up at your friend's
house yeah and you wake up the next day
and you're on the floor
yeah like I woke up and the window was
open we were freezing
and he was in the window watching a bird
in the tree like making that fucking
noise yeah I never heard that noise I
never say what's the noise when a cat
sees an animal that's he's about to
attack he'll make weird noise and an
hour later we the mother made us all
breakfast and gave us a lecture on why
not to drink and you know yeah yeah look
what the would look what's gonna happen
with you guys yeah don't forget
Christina opening the door that bird was
in shambles
Oh like he brought it to us as a gift
yeah then the mother explained she said
I don't know what he's gonna bring he
shows up with fucking dead cats yeah but
that was my only experience that we
would cast and then 30 years later go to
people's homes they have a cat the cat
jumps on yeah yeah
they show you infection that's what I
call you you get scared and you push
them off yeah that's that's part of the
fear that I had yeah yeah
then it's weird once you save a cat they
remember that they they if they remember
everything yeah I used to have a friend
that go don't fuck with cats cuz they go
into the bed and they write it down and
they gave you later my wife these cats
will come into the house yeah by the
time we both needed each other like it
was the weirdest thing yeah and when I
come home at night I'm doing comedy
they're scattered but once I go to your
office and I make my notes about my sad
and what I got
do the next day yeah once I go in the
living room and unwind they come out one
by one attention and talk to him and ask
him what's going on with their world at
7:00 Oh some of them don't come out two
of them you'll never see the two girls
yeah
Lulu Evie Evie lives by the door so I
touch her and touch her and the way in
and out
that's my good luck charm yeah she lives
by the door she watches that fucking
door I wonder if I would just go into
fits of sneezing and like and weeping if
I walked into your place because I have
like no I brush him I really keep the
gander to dander down yeah yeah I've
been around cats where I slept at a
place in a friend's place crash there
for like six weeks just out of college
and he had two little cats and like my
eyes would just start to you know water
yeah yeah yeah I don't know I mean I
never like I said that was my first
exposure and then they would chase each
other in the morning no and they would
like run over my face as they're chasing
so I have like cat scratches on my
forehead like right now you guys have
dogs yeah yeah yeah a child you have two
of the things that bring you the most
love yeah yeah you know you just wanted
to leave the Ohio
yeah it fucking snowed yeah Saturday you
were expected to sell out but then you
get the airport the flight was delayed
Thompson girl was fly this delay and he
was supposed to go to Bert crisis
birthday party yeah yeah you fucking get
home and you and your luggage is lost
and now the uber driver ain't showing up
and you walk in your door and you gotta
take a shit and you have all these
things but that dog comes up to you that
fast you really want to kick that dog
yeah at first you want to go you know
what do me a favor get the fuck away
from me what he doesn't understand now
he just wants to give you this elation
and I'm gonna tell you something when
you bend over and just Pat them all
those problems you had that morning
you're a human being yeah they just
disappeared it's true it's absolutely
just go away from five minutes and you
pick them up and you pat them and they
look at you and for five minutes
yeah at Toms delayed
we're not gonna make merch party but it
all seems a lot better that's 100% true
it really even with your child sometimes
you come home you didn't get the
audition they gave it to somebody else
and you pick up your kids you go I don't
give a fuck of Ralph's blows up right
now yeah I don't give a fuck I got my
kid yeah yeah that's what we're both
we're both three of us are all prefer to
be home I think the three of us are like
head our animals and play with our kids
and watch you know TV my happiest time
in life my happiest moment of the day is
when we put the baby down he's had a
great day he's in his crib he just fell
asleep
Tom and I are laying in bed with the two
dogs and we're watching some stupid show
yeah that's my that's why I live yeah
everything else is like I know it's
almost like you lived the day to get to
that moment right now it's really like
you can I feel like that I can feel that
clock counting down to that moment later
in the day yeah you know like when it's
30 minutes away I'm like oh we're gonna
be in bed what I think with dogs
watching TV pretty soon pretty no - yeah
it's funny how you know we all became as
comics and when you become a comic you
know like right now me and Tom lost a
lot of weight because when you become a
comedian you put all your focus into
becoming a comedian
yeah health they got onion rings at the
ball right answer you'll eat yeah onion
rings you go back to the hotel room
Doritos yeah whatever
don't worry it's it's so weird how we've
evolved as comedians but at the same
time now you like family like Led
Zeppelin was great awesome Led Zeppelin
the fifth album everybody started
spitting out kids yeah now the toys got
delay yeah and you know cuz you see the
only wait a second I gotta go on the
road and do what I'd much rather just
play on the fucking floor with this
child of course whatever the fuck it is
it's uh ya know man
I know it's a being home is it's like
it's the goal now like you just try to
design your life thinking at home as
much as you can do
the first fucking ten years you just
live on the room yeah it's just horrible
I mean my goal is to just not first of
all to not wear decent pants like I
always want to be in sweatpants number
one like that's the whole dream and then
they'd be home is like to do as little
as possible yeah that's the whole goal
for me like I want to retire at 50
fuckin dogs I always had a really big
respect me as a woman comic and I didn't
want to say woman comic as a comic
because when you were around me I didn't
feel like I had to act any differently
you know yeah
so I was very concerned about you when
you had your child you work you know I'm
so glad you're bringing this up I was
very concerned about you in your career
in fact Tom and I had a conversation on
a plane that I said to him how is
Christine handling this because I have
friends like Joe Rogan that they'd give
a fuck about the Mars and yeah if the
world is flat and look at this animal
and I could give a fuck about that I
love humans I love the mind yes yes
loving human psychology and I love to
see the change of people nobody nobody
nobody changed more than my redneck you
know my wife is at work my wife is one
of those people that job is 8 to 5
that's on paper in her world it's 7 so
when the job gets done right you know my
wife is one of those people that you
know she you took a job yeah you took it
for $10 an hour you got to do the work
yeah you don't like it quit yeah but why
you make a commitment they're Americans
yeah they're people that my wife had no
days off and 10 years as an accountant
she never took a sick day never took a
personal day she took 3 hours one time
when I was doing coke because I got like
an 18-grand check and she wanted to make
sure to check made it to the bank and
that's like coke dealers out it was one
of the biggest checks I ever got ever
for residual she left she took a train
you know when my wife had the baby
really yeah my wife said I'll be there
in five minutes to help you cash that
check and to put in the proper that was
the only time in ten years a top at the
Walt Disney Center she had the child she
had all this sick time
she had all this paternity time it was
like five months and I could see her
going through paperwork at night gung-ho
about it and then she had to go back to
work mm-hmm and I tried to help her I
tried to you know what do I cook
Hamburger Helper yeah you know to help
with Joella Coco chicken ala Coco
chicken cutlets with lemon and yeah
that's kinda Joey specialties yeah I
know three recipes I think everybody
only knows three that's all my wife go
for 40 hours a week this gun-loving
toadying american who believes in the
dollar day you know day's work for a
day's pay I saw kind of how it's 2:30
then 25 then 20 and then she came home
and they she was I'm just gonna become a
consultant and I don't no you're not
you're just not gonna work
you're 45 this is never ever gonna
happen again unless for some miracle God
give me another squirt of good nut juice
yeah you ain't we were lucky we got this
little squeeze and that juice out with
all the marijuana I smoke and I saw her
transformation so I was always real
interested in Christina's transformation
yeah I was very interested when she got
pregnant how she was gonna react to it
and you know online fat do you have the
child so now she doesn't work right wife
yeah I won't I tell her what's the use
yeah what if she came home two weeks ago
with some story about a AFI hey if I
want for the six figures and she'll put
mercy at the caps of school over there
and as we were driving one day I go take
a look at the one-on-one mercy and then
drive her home and then I'll guess who's
cooking at 6:00
chef Diaz chef boy a dick yeah cuz I
know how to make steak UM's and all I
the French fries with American cheese on
white bread to stay comfy it stank I
grew up on that yeah we all did white
trash it
I said why are you your transformation
was and it's so weird out he's so funny
you know I love women that are dumb and
one day the uterus calls yeah
what's the uterus pause that said that's
the biggest call a woman could get yeah
everything goes out the window
oh that's interesting you say that I was
because I thought about that the last
time I sat down with you when I was
pregnant with Ellis I think and you said
to me don't ever become a woman
Christine don't ever become a woman and
I was like why like what what did you
mean by that because I've literally been
thinking about it for like two years
when your atomic you're a savage yeah
you're not a woman you know you're on
the road with me I'm not gonna try to
hit on you but if we're in a room I'm
gonna for it
yeah you're gonna inhale it I'm gonna
take my shoes off yeah and you gonna
smell my feet and it just becomes a part
of your life until one day you become a
woman and go alright why am I sitting
next to this fat fuck talking about
eating pussy and giggling at his dumb
jokes
yeah and smelling his feet this breath
because you were a comic tolerated it
but one day the universe takes over you
like why my sickness is criminal why
whoa what is like what is my proof
there's a good point now I'm thinking I
do it with my life ya know you can damn
it you're a woman now who's a mom and a
comedian now yet and now you have to
balance that that's right because if you
you get a nanny and go on the road 40
weeks a year to pursue anything I'm
gonna pay for this in 10 years yeah yeah
Pennzoil commercial in the pens oh yeah
you could pay me now you could pay me
later yeah so now you're in a tough bind
now he has to know mommy does comedy and
it all works out and if you squeeze out
ten weeks which you'll be you're gonna
walk to the airport those ten weeks you
don't say you know like all right honey
I guess I see on Sunday those weeks when
you're leaving yeah what's he turns four
it's like Tom fuck you where's your book
I'm running to the fucking Airport
and Sunday I'm taking the late flight
back you and Joe Diaz with that 6:00
a.m. flight yeah fuck you I'm taking the
four o'clock flow sleeping late we
talked about this the other yesterday
that the thing that's great about the
road now when you when you're a parent
the really the the moment of it like the
thing you savor is that you have no
responsibility yeah you're there I'm not
on duty for eight hours you really feel
like yeah and and what we talked about
is that the best part is enjoying the
hotel room yeah it's it's watching
movies ordering room service in a row
and like and and like you know you you
have all the freedom to just do nothing
yeah it's Friday night yes my favorite
night on the road Thursday we got to get
up for radio Friday you're not
responsible for anything that's when I
go back and I cut my fungi toenail yeah
and I sniffing my throne behind the beds
and you rub out your feet with the thing
and you scratch deep into your nutsack
yeah you try to figure out why you have
a lump next few balls yeah that's Friday
night I love that I love it I don't have
to get up Friday morning I get up
Saturday morning I get the Hindoo eggs
again white bread there's always a new
people you wake up you go back upstairs
and you sleep 21 you get out because
agenda lunch a little college football
yeah you called Tom how's the baby
yeah great oh you have to see that's
great yeah I mean look I have modified
my life so that I'm not out nearly as
much dude it's like I'm out 48 hours and
then I'm fucking home dude so you know
what I mean like I just don't do as much
bullshit and you find that you don't
need to do I don't fucking need to do
Wednesday through Sunday bro like it's
not even going down I don't even fucking
do Sundays because of you actually
Lord's Day that's what I'm saying I'm
home
like I'm fucking here my kid all my
husband my dogs I think you inspired a
whole generation of people they should
call it like the D a lot of divorces
yeah I saw people disenfranchised and
really think about what you get on a
Sunday I want you to really think what
you gonna sign that what kind of piece
of shit okay twenty years ago we got
people that padded the room on Sundays
yeah who does nobody would come to see
us on a Sunday we were opening for Joe
Joe would leave on Saturday and I'd be
the answer that stays Sunday yeah and
try to sell tickets by myself and then
ask myself why I was doing it even
though I was single when I got off the
coke I realized something that no matter
even though as a comic I'm still a man
yeah and even though I was single and I
had a girlfriend I had no responsibility
to it
there's nothing replaces some they did
it yeah ways to Sunday dinner nothing
replaces Christine pass the potatoes Tom
what's going on
nothing it nothing your kid I don't give
a fuck what you do Sunday night yeah I
don't give a fuck of Sunday night you go
to a strip club and stuck your tongue up
a strippers ass all right right but
there's nothing like Sunday dinner with
your family it's true whether it's a
girl that you date and that's it because
it's not worth the paper yeah it's a
little paper you don't get you're gonna
lose that girl and ten years from now
what are you gonna do
Sunday's are so depressing to spend on
the road it is it's absolutely worth as
a feature act that used to kill me yeah
- wait hold the clock show then you
missed that redeye yeah you can't buy 20
minutes you always meant like if you do
Vegas Vegas yeah and the show starts at
9:00 you like I'm gonna go home there's
no flights have to 8:35 they'll leave
late Phoenix same thing yeah you got
like an early show on Phoenix fan leave
early on Sunday night you missed the
flight by 24 10 minutes it's worse every
fucking airline misses it by 20 minutes
yeah that's right
I love getting home early Sunday taking
a nap by the time I wake up at 2:00
they're alive
yeah yeah I got her all day you know we
play ya know Sunday is the best feeling
especially coming off of work like
coming off a shows to come home Sunday
have a Sunday at home yeah and I make
Sunday dinners the best we do Sunday
true my agent he's always like you don't
like going on the road do you you hate
it I'm like of course I fucking hate it
I did it for a decade I've been done the
road bro now he knows like but now my
deals are better yeah right cuz I'm like
I'm fucking doing it dude until my deals
are and that's also a joyous lesson yes
or you were even moving tickets I
remember like we were all you know like
lucky to get work basically right we're
horse and this is like six seven years
ago and no none of us were moving
tickets and then I'm talking to Diaz I'm
like yeah he goes are you doing Sunday
shows and I was like yeah of course he's
like yeah I don't do him and I go like
how do you not do him because you just
tell him no and I was operating from a
place of fear quite like how what if you
tell them I won't do it he's like then
you'd it what if they'll give you the
work it's like that you don't do it
that's right but then he said it no so
much that then they like all right
here's your Thursday through Saturday I
was like you have to do fashion oh you
want to fuck with me I'll book the sons
that threaten me with Sunday not take it
but I guarantee I go to their own movie
that Monday all right I don't have to
leave on Sunday and well then you fucked
yes I'm not gonna drop Lonnie until
Friday Rob Chimel style yeah you know
years ago nobody remembers this
Rob Gemma had Thursday through Sunday at
the improv for like six months of Rob
Sherman was hot 98 yeah
but they created this show called like
how to marry a millionaire or something
yeah and guy was a comedian and he was a
comedian from the early 90s who used to
light his pants on fire that was his
opener one opener where do you go after
that and he would go is it hot in here
is it me you know he was a funny comic a
stuff and for the revitalize his career
so what the Improv is do they go Vons
they took everybody's Thursday away and
they gave it to him
so shimmer will go okay you know what
time shimmer would cancel on Friday
like 6:00 p.m. 2:00 in the afternoon
oh you want to fuck up my Thursday yeah
I'm fucking with you Friday so he
canceled on you he did three weeks in a
row they never fucked with him again he
was a bad motherfucker man I didn't know
he was like that dawg he canceled
overnight with the facts she wake up on
eight o'clock they get some time for The
Improv on Friday sold out shimmer just
cancelled it looks like you're at a
lining Joey that's the way it is and
I've bumped into a man that bought watch
and he goes sometimes you got to teach
them a lesson and no no no - fuck that
dealing with they want to sell you out
for money they'll never sell you out for
money again
he was a smart savvy kind funny guy
Robert Schimmel and Hungarian Hungarian
you know we live in a we've been we were
robbed for fifteen years right you ever
gonna check now and you looking at you
now remember when we used to ask him for
200 hours more and they told us they
didn't have it and now they giving us
this check you know whatever we got rot
yeah
so now you know they said they really
would do that did a lot of shit so now
even an old dog gets a warm spot on the
sidewalk at one time or another
yeah so now you gotta fucking pay the
freight bitch that's true and they all
complain the club owners like well I
mean how come they these big acts they
turn into dicks it's like what happened
and I go well what happened is you guys
treat us like dog shit on the way up
yeah now there's no fucking love left
bitch because you've been kicking us for
ten years someone you're at the top of
the food chain
it's time for you to get yours yeah cuz
you treat us like shit for so we learn
how to be assholes from my car yeah yeah
when you go buy a car now they give you
two options they give you when I sold
you a car whenever I sold your car I
just didn't sell your car I brought you
back a purchased number and I brought
you back a lease numbers you can see
both options yeah we have the same
option now yeah you can either take care
of us at the club we'll go to the
theater across
street I won't make as much money as
that with Athena but I'll teach you a
fucking lesson yeah yeah so you better
keep you you sell a lot of cheeseburgers
and Joey's on stage everybody smokes
refri the Joey Diaz show yeah some don't
come to me with there's no gay this left
this key this left yeah and I want it
yeah and if I don't get it that's it and
that's just the way it is yeah I know
they they really do fuck you so hard and
I don't want people at home to think all
these guys are whining no no I want you
to think listen it works also when
you're a Mason if I could become a Mason
tomorrow and I come to Cristina go cuz
she don't want you to teach me to be a
Mason she's only teach me for ten bucks
an hour how to be a HOD carrier HOD
carrier is stocking the Mason's knowing
how to put 16 bags of sand and making
cement and making sure they all have
cement they'll give me a raise every six
months to another two dollars or
whatever the fuck it is but then they're
gonna come with time where they gonna go
I'm sick jump in and now I'm laying
brick and I'm doing everything but
they're still paying me the short tenth
Yeah right and they're charging twenty
two for me right do you follow me 22 on
the bit so this happens in every
occupation that's right you know not
just comedy I don't want it this happens
in plumbing yeah where for two years
you're getting fucked in the ass yeah
they're going Christine how you doing
we're leaving you here today and you're
like yeah you're in charge of Tom and
Joey today make sure the pipes are up
while the wiring is pulled and so for
two years
you get fucked doing that too yeah
because he's out golfing and you're gay
he's getting things you know that's true
it's like any apprenticeship I mean even
to become like a doctor right you're
broke for the first what decade you're a
student you're doing your rounds and
then you graduate and now you're a
practicing physician I think in our
occupation the graduation moment it's
not as clear there's like a gray area
where all of a sudden you're moving
tickets and now it's like and you have
to fight for your graduation is what it
is I have to assert yourself I mean
what's that great story who's the guy on
the sitcom he's super famous now
Gardel Billy Gardell Billy Gardell yeah
he he was talking to somebody and this
is like right when he became really
successful he goes yeah man those $1,800
weeks am i right like he was still doing
them right even as that he was doing
television that's right so he didn't
assert himself for the raises and for
the the graduation you know yeah so so
so crazy a Niner and he's like a big
star yeah but I mean now he's of course
yeah but um good family busted his ass
for a while oh yeah absolutely
he's a funny guy was always on like the
side and he was always put on a good
show with a shitty sidekick yeah who
would take down the show he had 20
chances he was unlucky
yeah I don't remember he had the MBC
show with the black kid that was not
funny
20 million black people that are funny
they gave him the unfunny is black guy
everybody's funny his black guy could be
funny if his life depended on him so
true there are so many funny black
people Joey it's very true so so
Thanksgiving was a was a blast we had it
we hosted at our house we had people
over we basically didn't do any work but
it was totally worth it scram they
outsource to although to the Hindus have
them cooked for us and then I did the
Wilbur tour the Wilbur the will turn on
on Saturday yeah is amazing amazing
so super fun thanks everybody here in LA
that came out to the show also this is
one thing that came in a lot over the
weekend was are you gonna 69 at 69 so we
did this thing my dad turned 70 earlier
this year that's my favorite thing we
had a big family reunion and my mom you
know in mouth Florida yeah that's when
you went too far my mom's Peruvian and
she doesn't she's not up on any of the
lingo or anything so at this big dinner
I asked my mom I said you know dad's
turning 70 tomorrow are you gonna 69 him
tonight and she was like what she didn't
understand so we were all laugh and make
and just joke about how you know it just
just make fun of her how
naive she is right so we told people on
our podcast that you should do the same
thing ask your mom if she'll 69 your dad
when he turns 70 and they've been doing
it in videotaping the reaction I'm gonna
play a few of them for example the the
milestone like it 7 70th birthday right
you know when Tracy is about to turn 70
his last night of being 69 years old
would you 69 him No Tracy you look a
little stone-cold in the face there mom
do you think when Danes about the turn
70 do you think to celebrate that's a
like 69 Austin from Florida here's Josh
and Sarah this is a prayer mom on the
night before I check the pops turn 70
years old yes absolutely.we 69 just
where you got here
[Laughter]
that piece of meat was good always shit
she's mortified yeah mom doesn't even
know what the hell there's a Riley hey
mom mama dad um when he turns 70 are you
gonna let mom 69 you like the day before
you turn 70 yeah mom are you gonna 69
dad she was funny she got it yeah she
got here's Maxwell hey mama
when um when Dan turned 69 yeah I'm dead
69th birthday are you guys gonna 69 we
even got a Spanish submission oh yeah
[Music]
okay penicillin
celebrity value
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did she say what she said your
ideas
she said my pussy foot pussy the lips
will be too long hanging down covering
your eyes just take the pussy lips and
put them over your eyes like you're
flying on JetBlue
[Laughter]
you two are gonna be together when you
turn 70 are you guys gonna still be
together when he turns 70 night before
his 70th birthday you guys gonna 69 she
goes why does it have to end all people
that still fuck you out something about
like when you see some old lady what if
she was like the most prolific dick
sucker yeah you're like you assume like
oh she's an old lady she might have been
like I used to blow the whole block yeah
like guys used to just drain their nuts
yeah but you just assume because she's
old that she doesn't have any you know
sexual history you know but you might
well obviously or even my friends that
are moms now do I this one friend in
college that was such a fucking whore
like just everybody dumped the clips in
her and now she's super mom she's got
two kids he's always on Facebook like
posting the activities again like you
were such a fuckin whore like I think of
all the jizz inside of her yeah it's
gotta be a lot yeah Sonny was the same
person now I know but that's the thing
is that she's gonna you know a few years
later right 10 years from now 20 years
from now and one day she'll be just like
a nice old lady and someone will be like
Oh watch your mouth in front of her and
don't say right and then you'll be like
I've known this horse and she
18 every guy every guy on the fucking on
the block got a chance to ride yeah yeah
like when you think about your grandma
like she sucked so many days yeah she
might have you know she sucked your
granddad's dig for sure yeah that's
crazy how my friend's mom my friend dad
died about two years ago and I talk to
him a lot him and I will always take
growing up and I always ask him how's
your mom he goes my mom's a different
woman he goes because my dad was 15
years older than she was and she married
him when she was 20 mmm
so now he's she wasn't doing a whole
folk song and he goes his mom they go
out on dates you know the momma like
it's complete without this day's all
talk oh yeah
she's good for laxity she goes went to
see Hamilton you know they they have
these lives yeah that would be where
they gotta be doing something sure him
with Viagra and if you got a good heart
you're still fucking I just can't
imagine what a pussy looks like at 70
and when it would smell like every
smells dusty I saw one I've seen an old
one I saw one in 84 I saw honey what'd
it look like it was pretty it was pretty
gnarly how did you see an 84 you I went
and watched a surgery uh I was doing
this research paper on surgery like just
the history of surgery and they let me
go to the hospital and then they're like
you're gonna witness all these you know
OBG surgeries today and I was like okay
the very first one they're like we're
gonna remove a cyst from this old lady's
puss and I'm like okay and they're like
make sure you don't talk about it
because she's awake you know and I was
like okay and then they post you up
right underneath her spread legs they
under a pit and they go in there there's
like a softball sized cyst inside of her
and they pop it and it's shooting puss
out and everybody's like holy shit and
actually was a good thing that they
reminded us not to say anything cuz your
natural instinct was just to go like
what fuck now but we got everyone kind
of
but yeah it was gnarly man yeah it was
beat up well I've seen a hundred year
old lady when I was in high school I did
Christian service hours and we had to
change this lady for her hundredth
birthday and I took off her address and
I saw her labia hanging out through her
underwear like one of them was hanging
out of her panties and they get real
hanging the lips get like yeah well what
a dick and balls do when they had a
hundred they got a really hang over 54
it's no fucking beauty queen no when I
was 30 I had a nice-looking dick it was
rainy it was tight its veiny the
turtlenecks all fucked up now now the
balls got a real what are your balls
like my balls are just are they in the
water are they in toilet water well I've
always had naturally fucking big balls
yeah yeah now they're just but the dick
looks like Frankenstein's forehead from
not wearing underwear my helmet on the
zipper so I've got a thousand of those
scars on my dick
I would never show my dick to a young
girl yeah we go for 20 year-old said I
really want to suck your dick it would
be traumatizing for you sure hands bad
know suck a dick
never mind a 54 year old dick like
anybody who sucked Harvey Weinstein's
and they really gonna burn him Listerine
yeah I think that dick tastes are their
heroes God oh I can't wait till he comes
out with all the tapes of the women that
did suck his dick oh I see ain't that
stupid he's creepy you think he's got
tapes oh yeah he's got like a young
Angelina Jolie drinking blood he really
is Gollum no that guy's a fucking
nightmare
but then again you know parts in a movie
kind of worth it so dude do you um do
you remember a few weeks ago I played
you one of our listeners calling into
like this nerd fucking news show all
right the dad boners and it going like
keep it high and tight yeah two fucking
nerds were like keep it high and tight
so like it's like a catchphrase from our
show and they're calling these two guys
and these guys keep reading it on their
news show like their fuckin make-believe
Good Morning America style show it's
like a local yeah like these Justin hey
guys this is my favorite part of the day
watching from work really keep them
jeans high and tight every time Justin
why he gets you every time yeah okay
this is live at 13 ABC Wham where's Wham
I think it's in Rochester another guy
the left you could tell he suck the dick
how do you do you have to get the shirts
tailored to be that tight around your
bicep is doing that on purpose for sure
like that's what Ryan Gosling does - I
noticed but this guy his shirts normal
yeah and he gets him tailored tight
right well the guy on the left wants you
to know what's up yeah yeah Justin's
checking in from work hope you guys are
having a great and eventful day keep
them jeans high and tight second time
right yeah then let's go back for more
Michelle likes your jeans a little short
Justin hey guys I love your shirts hope
you guys have a great day keep them
jeans high and tight Justin we are
wearing jeans today and actually his are
a little high that's my concern
your jeans no not on your waist oh
they're a little short kilt um Carmen
dad sneaks on Ludd fucking pants on yeah
when he sits down it looks like his dick
is strangled too in these pants he's got
the European tidies honor hungry but
nice stuff so we're gonna read you a
little line you compliment us we're
gonna save your life I will say your
line so then okay
and like doubly fag they can they catch
on catch on in this next one yes and
then they they take jabs at us oh but
they do it in like the hacky
fucking lamest away so like they don't
say who we are but they do here I'll
just play it for you it was back he's
our guy talk to Justin it's white shirt
you've heard about Justin's efforts yes
both ties are on fleek hope you're
having a great day
keep them mommies high and tight we know
about your mommy we do we know all about
your son Justin not one mommy you got
two mommies
you got two quasi entertaining people on
a podcast
I can't let me sit in the basement
emphasize a little humor from these
comedians yes you know we could be
unfunny yeah but we are not know how
many gurus we don't claim to be funny we
don't profess to be we just are we just
write speak for yourself but anyway the
mommies do and we appreciate them for
the Q&A we don't seem to be funny we
don't profess to be no no we just are we
don't profess to have any Talent that's
right speak for yourself but anyway the
mommies do and we appreciate that yeah
their show hey it's fun hey it's fun oh
these guys are fun yeah okay their style
of humor is like make a bridge and get
over that's their job their base this is
our basement I think that this studio is
probably nicer than theirs oh yeah
basement that a guy that scored major
films built in our basement alright guys
you know what you are very funny
at wham how do they coordinate do you
think they talk they call each other in
the morning and they coordinate the
outfits probably shirt colors and the
ties and stuff yeah I think they
probably do I know that that they have
like he said they're just naturally
funny guys and I feel like the nice
thing would be if they heard about how
funny they are so what I would get you
know what why don't you hit these guys
up and and tell them so this is Scott
here Scott let's go yeah I mean I've had
13wham yeah Wow wham Wham he's uh he's
here we go so he's at Scott Hesco okay
AG AG t sk o h TT sk o tell
him telling like dude we were watching
your your show with Matt you are so
fucking funny you're the funniest guy we
have I thought I'd new comedy yeah until
I watched live at 13wham and now I know
what funny is now I laugh you and Matt
are too true comedy pioneers you don't
even have to claim to be funny we're
watching your show and you guys are just
that naturally let them know let's lick
the mommies on them let them know just
remind them i mean tell them you guys
are your studio looks great and you're
really fucking funny guys so make sure
you tell them that they they're
hilarious yeah yeah they're funny guys I
almost feel kind of I almost feel bad
for like they're just there's such
boners you know yeah they are they're
pretty bad um no but they're doing their
Rochester thing and you guys keep doing
it man we're probably very funny man
jeez speaking of boners we see sometimes
people get excited about shit that I
don't think you should get excited about
and we kind of called him we call them
dad boners like this guy gets excited
about you know the trans-canada highway
okay just to give you some reference
[Applause]
[Music]
like what do you think of that guy he's
fucking mind
he's never fucked outside this
stationary position if he ever 6090 that
lotta time doesn't drive you crazy how
but one man's chicken is another man's
fuck yeah yeah yeah so you have to look
at it from that you know it's like when
you take your kid to go see spongebob
look at their face yeah
their face is fucking this is God yeah
you know he's some dude making eight
bucks an hour right yeah fuck the
college degree you know weird like it is
weird what something it's like when
people come up to you and go I want to
show you pictures from my
vacation yeah I don't give a fuck yeah
yeah what's the best thing you did this
morning that offered me a tour your
house I don't want to see your fucking
bedroom all right yeah see for yourself
living room let's see the TV you invited
me over for breakfast where's those eggs
you were talking about yeah people want
to show you shit that you don't really
want to fucking see that's totally
rotten drives me crazy in that yeah I
can't see without my glasses so when you
show me a picture of your trip to the
Grand Canyon yeah I can't see it people
have to lie to you people say oh yeah
they drive me fucking crazy you don't
remember when you didn't have kids
somebody sing you a Christmas card we
could hate you when the report on the
year I've read them now I put the
picture that get up on the wall yeah
because I hope they do the same to me
yeah you know it's so weird how things
change we were talking about change last
night yeah how we were 15 years ago and
who we are today that's why I don't mind
getting called out on a mistake I made
all right you can't call me out on
something I did 15 years ago right
because we've all changed in 15 fucking
years yeah that you know you want to
call me out because when we were
shooting a student film Christine in
1998 I smacked your ass give me a break
I'm gonna ruin my life because I smack
your ass even though you had my pants on
and we're talking about how hot your
friends say yeah is yeah asses how many
times have you gone through a set and
people acting fucking totally totally
fuckin wrong yeah even the women are
acting totally wrong you know so that's
what's pissing me off about what's going
on lately we all fucking change yeah 15
years ago who the fuck knows what I have
take my dick out in front of Christine
and whacked off no but will Christine
wait to see if I've ejaculated no
Christine were the left who sits around
and waits for come to come all over his
stomach if you sit there
Christina went away it is bottner Oh
Christina would have kicked me in the
stomach and ran out of that yeah for a
fact yeah Christina hold on let's
discuss calmly I really like your
podcast yeah Joey I want to show you a
little bug under my dick
no well you know how many guys I've seen
jerk off in public no you a lot no I was
well I've seen guys jerk off in church
I've seen guys jerk off under freeway
underpasses in our blossoms in the South
Bay
Oh Redondo in front of our in front of
our house I parked his car homeless guys
in front of banks I'm telling I've seen
but but how many of them do i watch and
finish to completion fucking 0.0 you
know what I'm saying you can turn around
and get the fuck out of there yeah or I
call the cops I call the cops on that
guy yeah yeah it's it's everywhere I've
jerked off in my car what is its wife
well yeah you mentioned that one time on
that great yeah you gotta come down yeah
but I think one time on ex-girlfriend
call me she's telling me about her
asshole all this shit and I got so hot
in the 405 had to take that penguin out
and it B is in the HOV Lane it counters
a third passenger if the cop pulls me
over what is your second passenger right
here between my legs
[Laughter]
Michael Bret do you think those guys 69
the two mastered one of them what's the
69 for sure I don't know he'll suck my
asshole like a fucking chicken wings I'm
saying
[Music]
yeah damn this guy here gets real
excited about this today we're
celebrating something very special
my daughter's BFF is losing a tooth in
the most glorious and one-of-a-kind ways
it has never been done before I've done
my internet research okay so this is the
plan yes of course this is non-alcoholic
carbonated cider in a champagne bottle
we are going to remove it tooth by
celebrating I don't like it already -
okay what the fuck is he doing he's
gonna pop the corn si take the tooth out
no I don't like this at all that's
alright it's nothing why what at the
park when they come in I want to pop a
bond with my dick the poor dog is
embarrassed she's like my dad such a
dick sucker I mean he's a total dick
sucker
yeah he's damn it man he's done some a
lot of questionable shit yeah yeah all
the kids like the fuck you talking about
I have to say as a woman that does make
my pussy dry yeah
this is the kind of guy that finds those
two news guys funny yeah that's the
demographics does he live in Rochester
on wham wam I like what Chester do you
pretty there's stuff about it you know
when what do you like about it it's a
cold different yeah I've always been a
big fan of Buffalo something about
Buffalo I like the people I took a guy
on the road this year from Buffalo all
year
well yeah cool guy yeah the radio yeah
yeah Josh Potter yeah you know great guy
great guy Josh bother that's right
because he's worked with you - yeah I
love Josh bonds he's great he's a he it
looks like so he was like a young
pee-wee Herman picture coughing the
movie theater but you wouldn't give a
fuck even peewee he'd run off in a movie
about anybody if it happened now I
wonder if his career would be as over
you know I mean I feel like that's
nothing compared to today's standards we
got a sixth finger - hey hey Hitler's
I'm just a black guy that got a jail and
liked to fuck
I had to stop I had to stop my calm hug
to write this email about the question
of the advantages and disadvantages of
being born with six fingers as a glass
and musubi man with six fingers on one
hand I can answer this puzzling question
we in the sixth parent community do not
acknowledge a middle finger also from
experience it is not an advantage in the
fingering men women Simmons errs but I
believe it does add to the experience
when you rub rub rub
Thanks water champ and Christina
machines within please fuck my Triple D
slut wife your boy from the trans-canada
highway Sam the Rainmaker well you got a
lot of them in there that's quite the
know I can't wait sorry I keep thinking
about those two dorky newscasters is
when are the mommies rain the fury Oh
like they have no idea what's about to
happen
yeah to them yeah I know they're gonna
have some fun oh I guarantee we have way
more listeners than they do are you cute
they have no idea what they just fucking
did shutting down their Twitter but to
rein fury the
butthole research okay hey mommy's I'm a
regular shit to shower participant great
do you do that sure you show a lot of
pieces falling that you're in there you
overcome it what do you mean you're
showering and then pieces times you take
sometimes you jump in the shower
and you wake up late you run away you're
not thinking and you're like fuck I'm
supposed to take a shit before the
shower I'm gonna do dry off and go out
and start from scratch
yes no no no you're not around you don't
that shit in and you take the stick and
you push it down the hole three or four
times but my wife caught me my wife
called me one time throwing a piece all
right
she caught you throwing at one time she
caught me with my hand through all this
no influence oil yes she did oh my god
and and she got upset yeah wait a minute
but how do you shit standing I've never
just pop a squat right papa squad the
thing and in hotels on the road yeah if
they call I'll take a good shit in the
shower I don't give a fuck and it has
like those four changes and the beauty
of it is the shower has the four things
so it's like when you were a kid and you
had play-doh another level bro yeah bro
I don't fuck around there's no that big
shower the Presidential Suite that big
hole oh my god yeah on a regular day
though but I haven't done it about ten
years I'm gonna lie yeah it's nice but
if you take a shit on the toilet do you
wipe and then get into the shower or do
you just take it alright here's the day
remember a couple weeks ago when the
plane went down because the guy farted
it was really bad a couple weeks ago a
flight had to go down if somebody farted
it was really bad okay
I had the whole explanation to that okay
I'm a morning shit yeah I can't wake up
in shit I have to wake up drink coffee
yeah do a piece of nicotine gum that
gets the interior going yeah then smoke
dope then you smoke right so I open the
back door while I'm smoking
shit starts coming out of me so I'm
smoking while I'm shitting okay so
that's that first really really good
shit of the fucking day yeah and then
you go and then I take a shower my ass
is tip-top Magoo yeah and I have no
other problems if if I shit this maybe
like it's 6:00 and before I go out I'll
take a shower to go to the comedy store
okay so that's that's that one thing I'm
a morning shitter who's a morning
strictly no your morning noon night
middle of what happens like that dude
they got on the plane that day yeah the
plane had to be taken down at 10:00 I've
been there because you got up at 5:00
you ate breakfast yeah became before you
can take a shit you walk into the
bathroom at LAX and there's a tornado oh
shit orders have you ever watched the
middle of the men's bathroom yeah it's
ten guys shit no yeah and it just you're
like I'm not gonna take a shit on you
then you have the oatmeal you got on
that fucking 4-hour flight and your ass
at the two hours listen only an animal
for shit on the flight yeah I've done it
for emergency shits it's not like a
casual so if it's that I will hold it
till it's coming out of my hair balls
yeah eyeballs before I share on the
plane that's disgusting no it's gross it
is really what they do the best they can
because the suction yeah yeah you know
they do the best they can so what do you
think happened on that flight he held it
he held that he held it and you get
those pre farts yeah it's like when
you're driving home yeah you drive home
you don't need to take a shit once your
asshole processes the exit yes okay
Laurel can yeah but you hit violent yeah
as soon as your ass your eyes connect
with Laurel King yeah it's like two
miles
now what's your asshole hits the reps
there's a magnet on the off-ramp that
bullshit out of your ass
think about yeah because that first
light when you're going off that alright
yeah
you pray to God you go Lord if there's a
fucking God please don't let that be a
red light that oh my god there's always
a real life because that's Magneto
yeah pull them that last bump yeah now
you're at that light your foots tapping
think of that fart that comes out first
that depreciate fart is horrific yeah
you can't even tolerate it you got the
windows open you got the air on it's
thick it's warm it's really yeah and
once you go in you feel it slipping out
of your ass and that's tremendous when
you sit and that first 14 inches just
drop a little pieces like you know when
I was know CIE work-study program and
made us go there that's what my assholes
like when when you go to the SAP bread
factory it's a hole in the floor six by
six foot circle and there's a bunch of
Puerto Ricans with broom all right and
there's three Puerto Ricans with bags
eighty pound duck Christine it's all
pieces of the cow and the pig the hearts
the eyeballs does that you just see them
coming down and it smells horrible
then you see like three Porto Ricans
putting a salt on them and ten-pointer
because they sweep it into a hole and
that's where it gets processed it comes
I love my dog hot dog that's how your
asshole is that's how your asshole I
don't know I lost whatever thought I had
but didn't you recently have a huge shit
you were saying last week when I came
from New York it was for Daisy for some
reason correctly we take shits on the
road but they're not really good shit I
have to yeah it's not the shit I take
when you get home when I walk in that
door you put that luggage down and I run
to the back bathroom the shit I took was
like a chain when I flushed it you can
get a cane breaking like like a bone in
the middle come back and I see my wife
she went got a snake that came work
because I'm always fucking that bathroom
up I fucked that bathroom up so good you
can't take a shower like that really
because sometimes the shower over floods
from the shit I'd taken that back she
loves you so much
yeah I picked that house I pick a house
because of the bathroom yeah everybody
looks at living rooms and family rooms
yeah
if the bathroom ain't proper you're not
gonna live right yeah I want my bathroom
I just spread my legs out I want a
window yeah I want a CB radio I wanna
see be on the phone I want my bad I
don't know Playboy they have my wife no
playboy no penthouse yeah
books I want I want I like to I got the
bidet in there now oh oh that's a life
changer what kind you get the cushy that
we got that one here in the kitchen one
yeah it's amazing you put the hot water
when the hot water hit you that's the
best thing and when you open up that
thing I mean it really you little leave
you would not you can eat off your ass
it's like it's yeah and you take some
warm the right time I took a loofah yeah
you go to Bed Bath and Beyond and you
got a big loofah you got a good one but
you cut it into little asshole loofas oh
that's a good idea I have an L for loser
yeah every 90 days I change it I'm sorry
wait wait
with you you dispose of it one use and
gone every two or three weeks after the
fucking no but I don't understand how
are you washing it Joey listen to me you
take the thing and you let the bidet the
tushy hit your ass right yeah and it
takes all the chunks and fingernails and
all them all the big Chicago yeah
then you take rolling pay our toilet
paper right you wet it first then you
massage it this it's clean yeah now to
exfoliate the asshole
yeah because that's what nobody does
everybody washes and wipes but nobody
exfoliates the asshole yeah that is a
problem ain't a loofah and you take the
other one and you just you know
exfoliate that little asshole yeah and
later on later on when you're driving
you look a little drive and when
nobody's watching you stick your finger
in your ass and you scratch now yes most
tremendous it smells like that little
oof or like that little clam I bet you
join us a really nice because I want
somebody like it nobody's ever licked it
but if they're ready to lick it no
decent woman no woman that's gonna bury
her children he's gonna fuckin eat your
ass your wife is eating your ass on the
rag no no but she's not she really
should boy we were datin she had eat my
ass one time if not I can't marry it you
gotta suck the ball suck and just pick
up that canal and lick that asshole like
the Sun thank you and you have to be
drunk to do it like you know if you're
not gonna get a single woman to lick
your ass unless she's a savage you're
assholes the first and that gets WIC and
they could smell like Newark they don't
give a fuck you got good pussy and I
bend you over he's 69 your ass from
behind and it's got a Wang to it you
think I'm gonna tap you know Christine
now you got one either with that way
these are real committee should have
planned like the other little rocky
bunny because we had a debate on this
show that this guy was like the only way
I'm gonna eat a girl's butt is if it's
totally clean it doesn't smell yeah it's
like love it doesn't love it no I don't
want to eat you push him you come on
this show yeah I want you to go to yoga
yeah I want you to come back from yoga
with those little pubic hairs lost what
stomach starting we just went to fight
we went to loofah in your butthole
asshole it's treachery it's tremendous
it's not it smells like a gyro you know
Jerry gyro uh heat whatever the fuck it
is right above the quick link I gotta
tell you this so this guy now you know
why don't you Lincoln this fuck I agree
with you and Lincoln dense that's a
fuckin stupid what is Lee people send in
some song submissions you want to hear
yeah so crazy isn't it and and machines
with it so this guy has been making has
been like Terminator gun yeah machines
but this machines worth in T 16 - 16 -
16 - 16
machines with them machines with this
guy wait what do you think what do you
think of a song like what do you feel I
would think that's a song is t 1660 so
much testosterone levels T 16 T 16 nice
guy but you can see where it's the
kernel of like something good right like
it could be a good oh yeah yeah he's on
to something nobody yeah I remember I
told it once he picks me yeah
listen that's a high-level script but
don't tell nobody
he's looking to be like why go cause
everyone jump on it tell a soul but not
a soul keep it we're gonna work on it it
was that bad yeah yeah
it's weird when you talk somebody down
from a man yeah but this like he said
there's definitely something here yeah
so this came in for machines with intake
[Music]
this is great mushy mushy
good
[Music]
yeah
this is good very good
[Music]
yeah this is a pretty
Sean powers from Johansen Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
the other guy didn't have a studio yeah
that's right now you have access to the
studio that day that's right Jason from
Sacramento did an acoustic version yeah
of machines within yeah I haven't heard
it but we have some very talented
listeners musically inclined people who
will take the it's very very nice I
actually think that's beautiful
yeah so last week the same artists
submitted another song this guy it's a
dachshund my song I just made on
Facebook isn't it drop that Bursa for
you crazy
isn't pazi first drop that first got the
knife crazy isn't it got that knife
crazy isn't it crazy isn't yes yes yes
this is the same guy that was walking
down the street the same guy for best
you must be a fan of Telemundo
he likes that fucking wrestling best I
do first how crazy isn't it innocence
innocence crazy innocent isn't incident
innocence incident isn't it so he did
that strange
and then people started sending in their
versions that's action my song I just
made on Facebook it's called crazy
[Music]
Firebird
that's a variant yeah I think he's right
right will some pristine this is a
[Music]
[Applause]
demonic right and there's a last one
here this is by Adrienne trap remix
[Music]
my favorite I think I'm a fan of trap I
think your theory is always been right
he just needs to be paired up with the
right producer and that's what these
initial passes are this is the first
round of producers that have stepped up
yep next week the week after we're gonna
hear at different variations on the song
just so people know so for this whole
week you can get 15% off on my store go
to merge method calm slash Tom Segura
use the code cyber 15 CY BER 15 you get
15% off everything in the store just
glass and bikes machines within the
Santa wears jeans hat all that stuff
how people asked me about machines were
thin guy about his shirt it he is
getting money for it so he's we've
reached out don't worry about it again I
definitely have a check coming to him
anyway so go to the store the only thing
not gonna be on sales there's a charity
sweater
it says Santa Santa Claus wears jeans
and that all that money goes to
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles so
that's not on sale but everything else
is vinyl all that shit finals crazy
people a vinyl so I think that's about
it Jean we have one other thing here and
then it's time to go first of all thanks
a lot Joey for coming by thank you for
having me I can't see the house the baby
yeah she's beautiful little boy you guys
did good thanks
he's a good kid somebody wrote to us I
went to the post office as you know post
offices are fairly quiet for the most
part as soon as I walk in I hear an
older lady blaring Church music through
her phone while waiting to be
when her number was called she didn't
turn off the music she just set her
phone on the counter while getting help
by the employee all of us there were
stunned no one said anything should
someone have said something or let it
pass I really I didn't really mind but
it was weird and uncomfortable thanks
Jesus Nicholas I think you're insane
yeah if you're walking around playing
music and then put your phone down and
play music through it I everything
people are crazy walking around playing
music when they're walking around how
loud for everybody like we all have to
hear your fucking musical preferences I
think someone should definitely say
something I disagree don't say anything
her she's out of her fucking mind
oh well you don't know what she's gonna
do to you no let her do it and just get
on with your life those people are out
of she's on another fucking reality dude
my respect goes up tenfold for people
that say something in those situations
I've been in a waiting room where
somebody was on a phone and there's one
of those office waiting rooms where it
says don't use phone and somebody else
in the waiting room who said hey get off
of your phone mmm I was like and then
the person goes excuse me she goes don't
you see the sign mm-hmm it says you
can't be on the phone in here and so the
lady was like hey I think I got no I
loved it I loved all that shit I get it
sold say nothing unless it really
affects me but yeah yeah yeah when
somebody steps up like that I think it's
the best man it really gets me excited
so go see Joey Diaz he'll be at the
Sacramento punch line you only have two
shows left you can get into December 7th
which is Thursday and yeah Thursday and
Friday like the arrow that shows the
Late Show probably is one of them so
that'll be the a Sacramento punch line
check out Diaz Christina P you can see
mother inferior on Netflix if you have
not yet seen it it's streaming on
Netflix she'll be in New York next few
days yeah I'm doing the stern wrap-up
show on Thursday so if you guys listen
to that I'm awesome so fucking excited
I'm such a huge fan and I can't wait to
nerd out and then she has her dates
available at christina p online mm-hmm
should come in to shark lake titties
certainly support portland horrigan yep
and pasadena and then Colusa Colusa
casino which i think i think
and I did that together my favorite
thing about well he had an edible with
him before a flight and I lost my mind
and he was just talking to all kinds of
crazy shit I thought I was gonna pass
out from laughing and we did a Southwest
flight together and he goes go sit by
the window and I go okay why he goes
I'll sit by the aisle
there's no way someone's gonna want to
sit between some fat fuck and then
remember that I finally like started to
come down off of this edible when I was
like and that was horrible that was
horrible and I come down there I go
I just I'm amazed at his tolerance and I
just can't believe how much you can
tolerate like I was really like having
anxiety I guess you don't he was like we
talking about I almost had three panic
attacks and I go dude you don't mind
what are you gonna do and then we walk
outside and I'm like thank God I'm
coming down he was you wanna smoke a
joint anything for years yeah he was
right back how do you deal with the
panic attacks that's why I can't take a
lot of you what breathe just breathe do
you talk to yourself like don't like
yeah you feel it and you're like I chill
the worst panic attack as if I eat an
edible to have to do something run
upstairs or that's when I get panic
attacks like something active has to be
done eyebrow yeah okay but besides that
I'm pretty good yeah well yours so okay
do you do an activity to ever like watch
TV to calm yourself down sometimes when
you're too high I just go to sleep
really high I'm too high I just passed
the fuck out yeah I get to that level
where you just want to walk too deep I
remember we got to Colusa I still
remember this we got to Colusa and
they're like you guys wanna go in the
buffet we were like sure but I was still
had that like after high where you know
you know you're not as hungry as you
think you are because the weed is making
you feel like you have money yeah so I
go to the buffet line and I come back
with a salad because I'm trying to fight
the feeling of just overindulgence
I'll eat myself sick is what I feel like
so I I shop at the table and then Joey
shows up when he's got like four plates
of like they're all different treats and
he's like who the fuck are you and I go
when he's like eating a salad
what are you a fucking for a weekend or
something some shit like that and I'm
like what I know I don't want to eat
crazy he's like go get yourself
something to eat
come back here with real fucking food
and I go okay fucking the points yeah
we fucked the points big-time that the
way watching points with two stones
we're stoned out of our minds you're the
best dude thanks for coming with Kelly
great podcast
I love the videos I love you quirkiness
and I wish you guys member success
you're a great couple
so thanks brother we love you thanks
guys for listening we'll see you next
week Santa Claus is black how come you
know Santa Claus is Latino Santa Claus
is Asian cray cray Santa Claus is black
Santa Claus is Latino Santa Claus is
Asian Santa Claus is black cray cray in
the Claus is Latino Santa Claus is Asian
crazy things down our energy Channel and
our route it's helpful we make
close down Santa Claus is black Santa
Claus is Latino
Santa Claus is Asian our secret
releasing ritual real news for the main
montage is black Santa Claus is Latino
Santa Claus is Asian great great Santa
Claus is black Santa Claus is Latino
Santa Claus is Asian Santa Claus is
black Santa Claus is Latino
great great